every morning I go to a cafe and order a
coffee for son I connect to the Wi-Fi
before I even open the newspaper usually
it's free the list of networks I connect
to you tells the story of my life the
network at my gym the one where I work
and the one at my cafe I wanted to know
more about these wireless networks I
look through the documents given to
cafes and other places where they want
to install hot spots
I read your clients are likely to leave
their Wi-Fi enabled this is a valuable
opportunity for understanding of the
Arth how they move around and what for
in the long run this technique will
improve the profitability of your
business Facebook will soon offer us
free Wi-Fi in certain hotels but only if
we login with our Facebook accounts that
will allow access to all of the data
about a stay and of course Google
already supplied Starbucks while doing
my research I came across a little story
to access the free Wi-Fi and a Lenin
cafe customers had accept Terms of
Service that included a clause called
Harrod this clause stated that the
connection would be made only if the
recipient agreed to give up their oldest
child for eternity what did the parents
do they connected to the Internet of
course the IT security company that
conducted this study admitted it was an
experiment and the children were allowed
to remain with their families
the purpose of the stunt was not to
abduct children but to encourage us to
read the providers terms before
connecting to free Wi-Fi
the mobile phone is actually a computer
but it's a computer you have no control
over right so it actually is
communicating with cell towers Wi-Fi
networks Bluetooth way more data than
you think is being taken by everybody on
your phone whether it's Apple operating
system or the apps or whether it's the
light the cell phone carrier or Wi-Fi
networks that you walk by that are
collecting your information and so that
it's really truly a device that is like
uncontrollable it's transmitting in all
different ways and you can't really see
what it's sending out about you my
smartphone is one of my most personal
possessions until now I thought my
secret code was enough to protect it I
don't want to see it fall into the hands
of a stranger or frankly even the people
I'm close to